Конфлікт на Донбасі - європейська проблема, а Україна - європейський форпост
про це  президент Порошенко заявляє з трибуни Мюнхенської конференції,
демонструючи прапор ЄС, привезений із прифронтової Авдіївки.
Порошенко вкотре обвинувачує Росію у зриві мінських домовленостей
і закликає Захід не залишати цього без відповіді.
Рішенням проблеми називає місію "блакитних шоломів" на Донбасі.
Москва має шанс показати почуття компромісу
і погодитись на миротворчу місію на всій окупованій території Донбасу,
включно з непідконтрольною Україні частиною на кордоні з Росією.
Раніше російський президент Путін заявляв, що Москва згодна
на ширшу присутність оонівців, але тільки як супроводу спостерігачів ОБСЄ.
Ідею України та Заходу про місію, що дбатиме
про тривале припинення вогню, росіяни відкидають.
Ба більше - обвинувачують Київ у спробі ескалації.
Поки, однак, відповідні зусилля і в контактній групі, і в нормандському форматі,
відверто саботуються Києвом, де на офіційному рівні заговорили про військовий сценарій.
Запровадження місії тим часом активно підтримує Німеччина.
Її міністр закордонних справ - Зіґмар Ґабріель навіть пропонує Росії пряника -
поетапне зняття санкцій в обмін на перемир'я на Донбасі
та згоду на введення миротворців.
Позиція Ґабріеля - спочатку в регіоні має стати безпечно,
а тільки потім там можуть пройти вибори, як це передбачено мінськими угодами.
Втім, ілюзій в тому, що Москва ось так на це погодиться, політик не має.
Ідея сильної миротворчої місії на Донбасі - великий виклик.
Я знаю, у нас та у Росії - абсолютно різне уявлення про те, як впроваджувати цю місію.
Але вона варта спроби.
Ми повинні не лише не відкидати цю ідею під час діалогу з владою Росії та України,
а наполегливо її розвивати.
Серед спірних питань - чисельність і склад "блакитних шоломів".
Колишній командувач американськими силами у Європі Бен Годжес говорить,
що долучати до цієї місії варто лише професійних військових із країн,
що не входять до НАТО, як-от Швеція або Фінляндія.
Мають бути дуже чіткі правила залучення до місії,
чітка командна структура, має бути визначена місія, а не просто люди,
які хочуть до блактних шоломів. Інакше це зовсім не допоможе ситуації.
За планом врегулювання на Донбасі, який пропонує "нормандській четвірці"
колишній генсек НАТО Андерс Фог Расмуссен,
забезпечувати мир на Сході України мають не менше 20 тисяч "блакитних шоломів".
Саме їхня присутність допоможе нарешті виконати мінські угоди, вважає він.
Однак обговорити план Расмуссена в нормандському форматі в Мюнхені так і не встигли -
устріч міністрів закордонних справ "четвірки" перенесли на невизначений термін.